Let's see if we can figure out 3/4 minus 5/8
Here we have a conception about 3/4
You can see this board
As a whole unit, and we see that it has been divided
Into four equal parts
Three of these sections are shaded
So these three are shady
This represents 3/4 of the whole unit
Which we see here
And then this board at the bottom you can see it
As a whole other unit
This is the whole other unit found here
You can see that this unit is divided into eight equal parts
Five of these parts are shaded
Thus this represents 5/8
We want to take the fraction 3/4 which is the area shaded in green
And subtract from it 5/8
How can we do that?
Even when looking at them
You may see the solution
Each time we collect fractions or ask them
We must think about whether these fractures are the same
Will we deal with four, eight or 16
Or any other number?
Let us think of a common denominator between them
And the best common denominator
Will be the common multiplier of these two properties
The ideal joint multiplier for these two fractions is the smaller common multiplier
And one way I like to handle it
Although there are many ways to do so
Let's look at the larger premises
Let's look at eight, and then look for complications
Eight, until we find one of them divided by four
The four are fully divided
But with the eight, we can say directly
The eight are divisible by four
The eight are clearly divisible
Thus the eight is the smallest common multiplier
For the four and eight
Thus we can rewrite
Both of the fractions are in the form of a number of eight
Thus we can rewrite 3/4 as a number on eight
And then we ask him the fraction 5/8
If we want to write a 5/8 fraction in the form of a number of eight
We will put it as it is 5/8
Then we can find out the actual answer of the subtraction process
How can we rewrite the fraction 3/4 as a number on eight
Well, there are many ways to think about doing this
One of them
I have number four in the denominator
Now I will double the number of sections so that the multiple sections are equal
I will hit the number two so I become
This number of shaded sections is twice that
Thus 3/4 is considered as 6/8
We can see this visually
If we want to have double the number of these equal sections
Both of these four sections are here
I will convert it
To double, each section is divided into two equal parts so we have eight sections
Let's do it
Let me ...
Let me swear this
I swear this
And this and that
Now we went from four to eight
We have one, two, three, four, five, six
Seven, eight equal sections
Six of these sections are shaded
3/4 is considered as 6/8
Now we can do the subtraction
We have 6/8 and we want to ask 5/8
So we have 6/8 and we want to ask them
one two three four five
These five are equal to the five purple ones
Located here
We will subtract one, two, three, four, five
If we want to deal with green only
We will begin with 6/8 and subtract from it
One, two, three, four, five
You can see that this is equivalent to 5/8 at the bottom
And now what is the rest?
Well, how much is left with us
The one that stays with us is 1/8 present here
So the rest is 1/8
We can see it numerically here
If we have six things and in this case 6/8
And we want to put five of these things
And in this case 5/8
The rest will have one thing and it is 1/8